up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel finished time to
get active what we doing today today we
are going to be interviewing Miami about
Andrew Tate we want to go out and ask
the people on the streets is he guilty
is he innocent what's up we want to hear
from the people but before we start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification Bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos and go subscribe to MTR meteor
tutorials and reviews less active why do
you think that she says because like
apparently he did defeated things with
girls and nobody likes it and he's not a
good person and listen I don't know who
he is so I can't speak on it if you
think in general we should assume people
are innocent until serving guilty yeah
it depends on what though
like it depends
depends on the church so if the charge
is human trafficking we should assume
guilty into a proven innocent no
so I guess what was the charge do you
think that there is a cohort of a type
of a person would assume that he is
guilty without tearing all of the
evidence but just based on the
accusation that he's guilted yes what
would you describe that particular
person to be I believe that it's all
from social social media okay and I
believe that people just have a word of
mouth so anybody that says something so
if you say something or you say
something it'll come from not I don't
believe anybody knows anything and I
believe it's all word of mouth if Andrew
Tate was a woman do you think that he
would be facing the same scrutiny yeah
the same exactly do you think do you
think if the charges
um if it's found that the girls were
lying about this do you think they
should go to jail
yes okay hi guys
um so I was just talking to trinise over
there and she was saying there's audio
um that just came out of one of the
alleged victims so we're gonna listen to
it and see what we think react live okay
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I got my thoughts I'll be honest with
you
I'll be honest with you
that'll mean why what's that book what
what's the book called with the uh the
dude that was beating uh ladies ladies
why did 50 Shades of Gray 50 Shades of
Gray 50 Shades of Gray thank you I
appreciate the assistance I appreciate
the assist that 50 Shades of Gray when
you've had Decades of suppression and
then that is the book that they read
that's what they like to do on occasion
that don't mean anything that don't mean
he was holding them against their will
this is what it sounded like to me it
sounded like they were doing like sex
stuff it was a role play
it was a role play and then now she's
trying to this is just my take I I don't
know we'll see if the facts come out but
like it seems like she was doing that
stuff and now she's trying to say oh you
joking with me too hard listen out of
context I understand how that could be
viewed but if you put it in the context
of that 50 Shades of Gray
some people are into that I don't want
to Kink shame curled out to Kink shame
okay so I'm not gonna lie I'm not pro
agitate and I'm not against them because
you know there's a lot of things on the
internet you can't really listen to what
you hear because some things are fake
and then some things can be true but
like deep down I kind of think he's kind
of guilty like you know there's probably
some things that probably like went on
behind camera that there's actually no
proof of but then again I also feel like
the girls that were in it also kind of
like because he's famous now so you know
who wouldn't want to try to get some
money out of a famous guy who got
billions of dollars so I feel like you
know it's two-sided
you could not do a business relationship
with a female I'll tell you why women
have sex with somebody
and that other person she's talking is
going to have the control over her mind
as opposed to you and if he controls her
mind and you don't control her mind once
she starts to pick it up a bit after a
few weeks a few months whatever and
realizes how to make money on her own or
she could run off and pay her boyfriend
or then to her to go traveling in
Southeast Asia and she's going to work
how she knows or she's going to go to
her boyfriend and say look [ __ ] it you
type for me oh yeah you're always
working I have to do some traveling and
you can't come I want to bring you with
me traveling is a great group because
the thing about this business is mobile
if you can find a good Airbnb with good
internet you can run it somewhere else
so it's a good little caveat to throw in
uh you're always working why don't you
work for me so we spend more time
together or if you're doing what say a
lot of webcam business oh I don't want
to do that it's okay I know you don't
want to do that but listen come let's
have a meeting let's just talk about it
we don't want to do it don't do it fine
let me explain it to you properly in
fact I'll bring one of the girls who
works for me
a new girl you go out for [ __ ] a nice
dinner your boat Mitch is the one who
does the selling you don't do the
selling the girl has to hear from a girl
and this is why you bought me just be
trained so I said it's so important to
have a good first girl remember Glenn
Maxwell that was the girl that recruited
for Jeffrey Epstein almost identical to
what he's talking about here
you guys remember so this is why this is
important this push right here it
doesn't prove anything but it is one of
the little piece of evidence that they
add in for the whole traffic in charge
basically he he has a woman okay who
used to be a former police officer in
Romania she's the one who does the
recruiting the managing of the women why
because women are much more likely to be
roped into these kinds of things if
they're hearing yourself oh they get
roped into these kind of things no oh
they chose it's like the language it's
like we always are taking accountability
off of the women where do we take
accountability for the fact you chose to
do that like okay they might not have
been
they the the percentage fine they didn't
know that but it's like you chose to do
it there ain't [ __ ] a boyfriend could
say to me to make me take off my show my
boobs on camera are you crazy you're
crazy we're gonna say to you they were
roped into it
the transition from will you be my
girlfriend to showing your guts online
how does that happen I I don't know like
that's never happened to me in any of my
relationships
you said to him I wouldn't feel like get
the [ __ ] out of here
get out of here like and
ah nobody was complaining when the money
was covered
you talking about the big a word aren't
you
taking accountability
I you've heard me say this so many times
everything in your life is your own
fault
if you get screwed over in a business
deal I will say that's your own fault
because you should have read the
contract
you should have paid more attention to
the note like honestly
honestly like I've had I've had points
for like I had an employee spend too
much on my credit card right like with
stupid amount more and it was my own
fault because I wasn't watching like
it's it's your everything likes your own
fault like did they did they look at the
tax form no did they Google if Bitcoin
or whatever has taxes no they're like oh
it's just easier okay
again
the lying about the percentage wrong
wrong maybe technically a crime
and that's what I'm saying he's not 100
innocent either but the way this is
gonna get painted is he's a hundred
percent yeah like the only person in the
wrong poor victim oh they are in a
country they ain't understand what was
going on
he was holding them against their well
he was doing this he was doing that yeah
I mean they're so dumb like children and
loving the mansion in the Mansion
chilling with the Bugatti and you do
there were 75 other girls he was [ __ ]
so it's like what do you think you walk
into a house with 75 other women in
rooms and with the webcams on showing
their their tanks to the world
yourself hmm I don't want to be involved
in this maybe it's not the best idea
maybe this is not the greatest of ideas
but see when you break it out like that
you begin to understand like some of the
mentalities I might go into someone who
will get in track like that so is it so
let's show us the wrong doing or is
there a
effort to Target a person who want who
folks want to take down
now where is the accountability
other women for being careless
even with the percentage I'm sorry guys
I just think everything in life is your
own fault I just I genuinely do on both
ends you know
it's it's on some level it's like and
tape would probably agree with this like
he chose to be on the internet this is
partially what comes with it what's up
my young Skyla how are you all right
listen so you know who Andrew Tate is
yeah okay do you think that he's
innocent well before we get into that
how do you feel about Andrew Chase how
old are you by the way you're 16. so
you've seen this content on what
platforms uh Texas okay how you feel
about Andrew Tate uh I think he is a
positive male role model he's your
teacher is not about masculinity and I
just think he's just positive and in
general has he taught you something
specifically that had an impact on your
life uh yeah he has uh he helped me get
into fitness because I was really fat
before and then when I saw his content
he told me to get my stuff together and
I started exercising I started reading
books I started getting my mental state
and my physical state in check I wasn't
really you know happy with myself but
now I feel like great ever since I think
and I really appreciate him about that
and yeah he just had a very
um strong impact in my life that's
impressive to hear that you were able to
go from one stage to another stage by
listening to his motivation now now that
all the information is coming out in
regards to him being in jail his appeal
being denied what is your feeling
regarding that do you think that he's
guilty or innocent uh I
I think he's innocent some people might
not think he's innocent but I think he's
innocent because it has no real proof to
just people saying this than the other
so it has no hardcore proof that he um
actually you know did what people are
saying that he did so I just think I
think he's innocent and no one's really
giving me a reason to say that he kills
me have you seen recent interviews or
like uh Court release documents of uh
text messages between himself and as
well as the women that he invited to his
estate uh no I haven't seen that okay so
I guess let me ask you a question so I
know he had a major impact on your life
what evidence would you then look at and
say he might be guilty if they actually
like find like proof like saying how
like what the other dude was saying like
text messages or like solid proof saying
how yeah he actually did that yeah of
course proof is proof but until then I
don't think he is so you need to see
hard core so the text messages would not
be enough
no
Nathan we got a quick question for you
you heard of Andrew Tate yes sir do you
think that he's guilty or that he's
innocent I mean he done a lot of bad
things I think I think he's guilty and I
think he's done a lot of things
what are some of the things oh no he'd
be manipulating women and he be doing
like she keep his schemes and [ __ ] you
know like a lot of scams he's Shady dude
he's Shady what what scams I know he'd
be promoting crypto but he got some
little sketch going on so you don't need
to pay tax to anybody tell your girl
that you're paying the tax because girls
are lazy girls are stupid and girls
don't understand how taxes work so the
girls working with you and you're like
oh okay yeah we've made this much money
but I'm gonna pay the tax to make sure
we don't get in trouble
she'll sit there go okay okay now that
allows you to do two things one is
another control element I work with him
my tax is not a problem if I do it alone
I have to deal with taxes taxes are
complicated and I'm just gonna pay her a
smaller percentage
so I used to pay my bill 13. so for
every ten thousand dollars they made I
give them three and I keep seven
they thought they were I don't think
that's that bad that okay the the 30
percent
to me that's normal if you're doing
everything else no I'm with you like
that's not even a bad percentage I I
think it's probably more than they make
by themselves yeah that's that's the way
I think it's like how many of those
girls could bring in three grand a month
themselves um
the other part where he's lying to them
about I mean because to me that doesn't
sound like human trafficking that just
sounds like you got Bamboozled so you
don't so you just heard about Andrew
Tate how long ago uh actually just like
recently like in the last couple like I
I there's a website called Jezebel yeah
that I love and I read a lot of it's a
feminist website oh my God and um that's
where I read about Jezebel it's called
Jezebel yeah interesting yeah that
sounds very appropriate yes but anyway
um so you just heard about Andrew Taylor
from a feminist website so I just wanted
to ask a couple of questions regarding
your current opinion regarding sure and
you say like how do you feel about him
just with a couple of weeks of yeah well
the impression I got from what I read
about him he I completely believe that
he's a misogynist piece that has a great
influence over a lot of people
apparently has a lot of followers and
and in the state of the world you know
he
um can be very impressionable to a lot
of people and it's something to not
disregard and he's also being arrested
for sex trafficking and that's the
[ __ ] thing as a woman that's or is a
man I have a son I don't care like it
would it's deeply upsetting what's that
you know so he's in uh jail right now
they just in Romania
six people I think him and his brother
and there's um some other women that are
also been arrested as well
um so so you understand him from the
website you see the charges against him
yes let me ask you what would it take
for you to look at to say no he's
innocent oh yeah great question because
you're right I'm off I'm very influenced
by it does it all so you're right like
and I'm so I I mean I take it you're
right that's a really good point
um
like I feel like if you're if you I'm
one of these people like if you've been
accused of that like it's hard for me if
something of that heinous of a crime
like it's hard for me to think another
way and I know that's like I'm guilty of
like just presuming guilt on somebody
which I and and that way with sex stuff
like that yeah why do you think that is
because I don't I don't think that's
uncommon like why is it so common for us
to think guilty until proven things yeah
that's a good question so
um
well I feel like in our society at least
in these days it's because we're given
the imagery of the person you know we're
in other countries they don't always see
the person it's it's not legal to do
that right yeah so you are you you start
to see a face and you're like oh like I
don't know if these girls came out that
they were lying do you think they should
face jail time oh if someone is yes
because that is also you're tattering
someone's uh you know damage no and
there is that there is that to be said
true I agree with you but I I actually
feel like it's much more on the other
side of people women and and men too
don't say anything about something like
sexual abuse and people using their
power to you know control you I I think
that's what I feel do you think that um
the I think what I heard you say is that
based off of the extent of the
allegations brought forward that you're
more inclined to believe that he did
those things do you think that there's a
construct or a culture where guilty into
a proven innocent is more so on sexual
allegations for men
versus sexual allegations for women
because there's women all across the
world such as like madams and like
Philip in the Philippines and stuff like
that that definitely engage in sex
trafficking uh operations but we often
don't care about those so I guess do you
think that there is perhaps within our
cultural society in underpinning of if
it's a man it's much more guilty than
proven innocent versus a woman that
would be engaging in similar activities
yeah I absolutely feel that I I think
that so much in the way we see the world
is more conditioned and I will totally
you know cop to that like about a lot of
things in life and I talk about that a
lot like what condition is what we feel
and think
yeah you have to check that [ __ ] yeah
because you gotta like why if the same
things that you read in the Jezebel
article was about
a woman
but it was Andrew Tate do you think that
they would be labeled the misandrist
as opposed to a misogynist oh I like
that yeah well King that [ __ ] the
woman uh with uh what's his name in
England I just recently the I can't
think of her name right now that was it
hamburger no not no I'm sorry the one
that was with the guy that killed
allegedly killed himself in prison um
I'm liking on her name right now she
just uh she's a British woman but yeah I
think why do you think the word
misogynist is so common but miss
sandrist isn't I've never even heard
Miss Sandra's I didn't know that so
that's basically like the it's the
opposite yeah oh yeah I've never heard
that isn't it interesting how it's like
misogyny is so readily used like we hear
that word all the time you're right but
we never hear Miss surgery and it's like
when we have open like men are trash men
are the problem
but if it was the vice versa and I'm not
saying you said that no no vice versa
like we would be so mad yeah I feel you
I yeah I have a son so I compassion for
men how much do you think that uh
watching the content that we watch goes
into the things that we believe
how much do I think like more than
people even realize I think it's so
powerful because we're so we're sucked
in and that's the way I don't know we're
designed that way or you know we're like
made that way to be highly
impressionable like tribal people yeah
yeah oh okay we're designed no and
that's what yeah maybe and then follow
or crack animal yes right so and that's
why I'm like that's why it's always
important to go like why why why why you
gotta ask that question you got
everybody you always no matter on the
side of the coin yeah yeah do you think
the women could be trafficked if they
weren't if they were allowed to leave
the whole time like do you think oh are
the women victims if they're if they're
allowed to leave
uh
that's a great question I think the idea
is a really good point he was like
saying that he was having the girls fall
in love with him but like allegedly I
talked to both sides today I know I like
it I like it it's like allegedly he's
very happy he held them he had them fall
in love with him right and then but the
whole time they could leave but they
were in love with him so they stayed but
to me like I'm thinking if I went to my
dad and I said dad I fell in love with
my boyfriend made a ton of money like my
dad would kind of be like but they're
the the ability the mind control and how
you could break someone down and that's
something that's also about someone that
that views of power and what you can
tell and they I mean you know there's I
uh you like how about you had a chance
to escape so why didn't you dude you
know like yeah I mean you question it
but there's someone control it's amazing
if you don't control your mind someone
else will if your son was accused of
what Andrew Tate was accused of
how would you think
I mean I'm gonna I I'm gonna I love my
baby so I'm gonna stand by my son until
like you know but I would also go like
how could I
raise a child to be on that man she
would assume guilty into a proven
innocent like Andrew take
yeah because if it's my family member
it's my people it's my you know part of
I'm gonna no
but it would be heartbreaking and I do
think about that a lot when people like
you know you have like what does their
family member think of them like what do
they do and how do they influence them
and why would they make that choice
right so
you know you know there's a case in in
um I can't remember what college it was
but it came out that a girl falsely
accused a guy to the point there was
video evidence of her like pulling him
back to the dorm and they still kicked
him out of school yeah and I think a lot
of times I think a lot of times we don't
like a lot of times think about it that
way for men it's often like guilty until
proven you're right and we have these
like natural strong inclinations to
believe women when women lie too you're
right oh very much and it's like who's
really more manipulative when you think
about it women are bad right like and do
we have the same energy for the women
that were manipulating the men and
getting hundreds of thousands of dollars
from them yeah like when they say oh
baby I love you like to the men on the
cameras send them their family's life
savings yeah but the women aren't helped
like they're not they're not called but
that's what they were doing oh no one is
holding the women that lie to the men
accountable they're holding Andrew to
the accountability yeah but in the
um feminine magazine they don't talk
about the women that [ __ ] on the men
and lied to The Men Who were never even
talking to the men their focus is on
Andrew yeah yeah yeah it's a really yeah
it's excellent to bring up I know about
it like a lot of times like especially
feminist media I've just found this very
like one-sided sometimes when we're
supposed to be about equality but
oftentimes it's not where we don't give
the men's point of view in my opinion
yeah I gotcha yeah
let's get weird like even Miss Sandra
it's like should it if we talk about
misogyny all the time should it feminist
magazines use with Sandra too because
we're worried about it and I've never
heard of that I've never heard and I'm
not just I'm too old to not know that
word yeah I'm seriously oh it's like the
open hatred ah yeah have you learned
things today that will change your
outlook going into the future I think
you guys did I think you guys not picked
it but scratch stuff and I'm like which
I love I'm like I'm the type of person
that's like you love information well I
like it I'm like make me think
differently yeah you know play powerful
conversation guys thank you oh my God
I'm a hug okay cool cool yeah cool no
you bad cool thank you so much like I
know it got kind of intense in the
middle of conversation but no I like I
like talking guilty you're innocent
innocent all right why why because first
of all it's not every day that you get
like Andrew take that just won't be the
best versions of them men and women and
then of course you have this makes
that with all this money Fame
acclimation numbers and stardom go and
do some dumb caught up on human
trafficking are you serious is that the
best you can do I'd rather you this
[ __ ] now you know I'm saying I'm
not on taxes Wesley Snipes that's better
way than this fraud
also
combined with a sex element
at 75 employees
they just want to take you out as a guy
now you add on top of that
being the top G
the most Google man in America here's
where I'm going to get we talk so often
about
you know how intelligent that he is he's
obviously so smart
why would you
knowing who you are
doing these things in the past
also want to be one of the world's most
famous people in the world and you would
think someone is as smart as him
wouldn't want to do that which leads me
to believe what components in here are
being taken out of context or being
simplified in a way in order to paint a
specific narrative yeah well and I
wonder like
lying to someone about a percentage
isn't necessarily illegal
verbally like I'm just I'm just thinking
out loud
well like if it's because I doubt these
girls really got anything in writing
like a contract
what he's saying 50 but then later on he
says that he wasn't giving 50 so that's
like
you sign up for such and such banking
sales and they say that well you're like
15 commission and you end up getting six
percent commission no I I'm with you I'm
just I'm just wondering if it's not in
writing and it's not like a formally
done contract it's not illegal
I mean here's the thing so they'd have
to prove that you know this is just a
thing that they can enter into evidence
to be allegedly right but then if
they have things in writing that says oh
they were getting because maybe maybe
his maybe a change from whatever he made
this video he was like you know what
let's pay them taxes and this is
predates where he was actually running
the business at scale
to see to say he's guilty
be guilty let me tell you something talk
to him
guilty talk to him
I need to [ __ ] dungeon I need
fingerprints whips and chains I need DNA
evidence oh I need semen on the door
knob you don't need that I need semen on
the door knob that matches this brother
I'm not guilty he didn't do it even if
he didn't do it I want to believe it why
why do you think um the internet is so
quick to believe the women because
that's why this world this world is
getting demasculated but sorry continue
the question no that's go ahead go ahead
why are they so quick to believe women
because women because women
are these delicate creatures that we
must protect but at the end of the day
women also have been at the you know I'm
saying at the very center of a lot of
allegations to where you have to be
proven innocent after you they think
you're guilty like Emmett Till like that
you know what I'm saying you have
situations where women are able to make
crazy allegations and then proven guilty
until you know what I'm saying yada yada
takes five years later and then he's
proven innocent and then nothing happens
to the female so we have this culture to
where the women is put on this High
pedestal make sure she's safe make sure
she's just in the court of law and then
we'll figure out what's up later that's
why I think the internet is so quick to
believe women nowadays now that doesn't
go to say that I don't think women
deserve to have their claims heard
another I believe in you know I'm saying
equality all around but at the end of
the day look
you know what I'm saying that's on you
let me tell you something men stop
giving too much of your meat money
energy attention time let me tell you
another one like that ladies ladies
[Music]
please be more like her she's fantastic
she's fantastic I recognize YouTube you
know what I'm saying yada yada ladies
we'll tell you something this right here
is fantastic she speaks the truth
um the interview when when when you had
taken right and then some other girls
trying to say something and then you
kind of checked it now I was like God
you're dead you know what I'm saying
well plus anyways my name is black and
wild you know I'm saying on all Medias
sir
I'm trying to get like you're trying to
get lighter you know I'm saying light
and brighter trying to get back here my
brother
so everyone thinks he's innocent I I did
see this one thing I didn't see this one
thing that it said like wait yeah he has
a form of like sex trafficking noise
like the lover boy that likes lover boy
sex trafficking but he gets women bro
like like him and then yeah and fall in
love with him and do whatever you want
but like yeah do you think that makes
the women victims
um not if they're doing it by their own
in a way they victimize themselves
though
tell me more because like Bro think
about it you are putting yourself out
there you're hitting him up like
he gives you an opportunity if you take
it
right I guess you got married
do you think the women would have made
as much money if they didn't
sign up for what he was selling them and
come over and do the webcam business
they probably wouldn't have made as much
money on their own I guess in a way he
put them on yeah think about it like
that well part of the argument is is
that it's human trafficking because it's
fraudulent because
he was telling her he was going to pay
him 50 but he wasn't but he made them he
was paying him 30 and acting like it was
taxes according allegedly accordingly
who said this yeah you've been to
Romania his own he has a video he has a
video where he's teaching how to do what
he did in his webcam business and that
video has been going viral on Hustler's
University I think it was on Hudson yeah
yeah what is he saying it he's saying
within it exactly how he gets the girls
to come over bro to be honest like it's
like
you obviously don't want to believe
someone is like human trafficking like
good person or not like yeah you're not
gonna like
if someone says you're driving I'm not
gonna automatically believe it I need to
see like some sort of thing no why are
people so quick to believe it because
people on social media it's 2022 yeah
also okay this is crazy Andrew Tate says
a lot of crazy that's why he's number
one hated yes but yo some of the things
he says bro everyone has to admit it has
some truth to it like solely camera
right now all right I'm gonna ask you
guys so what evidence do you need to be
like he's guilty
I feel like the frog in human
trafficking I would think would be
separate charges I agree with you and
that's where I I almost it seems like
they've at like human trafficking I
would imagine like 20 years ago would
just be
like
forcefully taking someone against their
well but it's like they've added in more
things where it almost seems like
they've changed the meaning I thought
trafficking was against your will yeah
so like if you ask someone to come
to where you're at but they have the
ability to be able to leave
is that human trafficking but there
seems to be a fraud aspect associated
with it now the tax fraud is completely
different so does the tax fraud which
could be a part of it and then the fraud
component within human trafficking why
do you think the girls seem to be okay
okay
it's money it's money it's money it's
money uh think about how many think
about how many YouTubers do gold digging
videos and how many girls like gold
diggers if they find out that the girls
were lying what should be the girls
punishments jail time just like men for
example for example girls are oh if the
girls if they find out that the girls
were lying all the accusers what should
happen to the girls listen it oh if a
woman falsely accuses a man of rape you
should go to jail it might not Rave
agree with am I not right
you should go to like like there's NFL
players like uh God the dude that was
supposed to go to Sean Oakman he was in
jail for like 10 years after he was
supposed after being like a number one
NFL draft draft prospect and the girl
said oh I made it up and yeah exactly
the girl said I made it up and he lost
his career
I don't why don't you think Society
pushes or punishes women for lying on
men if you really think girls have girls
can make it any way they want I feel
like it's girl if a girl was to offer
you ugly person who the [ __ ] saying no
okay that's the better females have
something everyone wants and it's sex
girls
have it easy they can be pretty if a
dude is ugly
go explain Little Wayne huh
so then guys do have something that
women want yeah but not all guys 18 year
old guys you think all all guys are out
here I'm not talking about all guys but
I'm saying that you have value too but
all women have what I'm saying and I
agree with you exactly I agree that's
the thing that's still venison coming on
men not to be sips yeah basically there
it is
in your head though like if you're not
mentally strong like
runs the world in front of weak men
let's get that let's get that to be
let's keep that up that's it for your
weakness at the end of the day
absolutely Andrew Tate guilty or
innocent
go see guilty tell me why not just any
man gets accused of human trafficking
man you know walks away with that does
accusations mean guilty
no because we need evidence but
what's the evidence that you saw that
points in the direction towards guilty I
would feel I feel like people would say
he's guilty because
or you know
I don't know I can see why people
support him and don't support him what
makes you think he's guilty like what
evidence
there there is no evidence but I would
say
women don't support him which is why
it's heavily influenced to think that
he's guilty okay well I'm just I'm
curious what you think
just wondering why
um
to be honest truthfully I
we knew the evidence before before we
could accuse him okay yeah okay so
you're you're on
let me ask you another question what
evidence would you want to see before
saying yes guilty like what would be the
Smoking Gun
uh the paper chart paper trail of
perhaps him text messages text messages
you know the people he was interacting
with that collaborated in this I'm
guilty or Andrew take guilty or innocent
I would say you understand
why
from what I've been seeing it's like it
doesn't it doesn't really add up like
um they've had a couple of accusations
before even the girls came up and
I really feel like they're just trying
to bring him down
I've watched a lot of his videos and
I don't know it just doesn't make sense
to me like somebody that powerful and
that famous would have to do anything
that heinous what what evidence would
have to come forward for you to think
that he was guilty I'd probably have to
like watch a video of it happening okay
so if you didn't see a video of it
actually happening of the trafficking I
no I wouldn't believe it like we're
going through uh like a feminism
movement and everything like that he
uses a key icon defending masculinity
anybody really likes that right now some
of the girls who worked for me I use
them to do other things
to move money or illegal things
documents and I will never do that with
you basically telling the girl you're
different from the others I make them do
the really illegal stuff again they have
it right here in the wiretaps okay the
hymn admitting to this stuff this is
going to be used in court and you're
gonna have a hard time explaining this
one away what is this money laundering
that you were doing you can't go to the
court be like hey what happened was let
me scratch your head yeah okay so now
here comes the next part this is the
mood I think the biggest one Tate's
Angels being the bottom of the two women
these are the women who work for him the
Glenn Maxwell's if you don't make money
we're gonna have a problem punch
yourself in the mouth until I arrive
because then I'll give you another 10
you incurable slacker
and the other girl says I'll break you
when I get there and the victim says
what did I do
and the bottom is you have one hour and
10 minutes to disappear and the victims
but what did I do you're down 20 four
days since you posted and she says if
Andrew looks to see you if you posted
tick tocks you won't even have time to
pack you're flying off the balcony
straight away
so what does this conversation really
mean this is where this is important it
might not mean much to y'all because
you're like well when they're taking
this in conjunction with everything else
the fraud element involved the coercion
element the aspect of like lying about
what they're really going to be doing
there the fact that this girl who works
for Tate is saying he's going to be
punching the girl 10 times when she gets
there there's these threats of violence
the one saying like age gets home you're
gonna be flying off the balcony is that
literally probably not but there is some
element there of threats of potential
violence which you don't do what's
needed
when you take that to court and these
are conversations that are happening in
private you understand they're going to
take this into strong consideration when
they're making their case they're like
how do you explain this stuff
oh we're just joking We're Not Gonna
actually make her well then why is the
victim terrified
oh she's just lying and making you think
that's gonna really be a real defense in
court you know the thing is um there's
some people are not going to believe
that of course there's going to be a lot
of guys gonna be like yeah this ain't
that bad it ain't that bad and you know
why because they actually talk like that
they talk like that with their girls the
girls I'm saying guys but I'm talking
girls do the same [ __ ]
oh my God oh my God I swear imma punch
you in your mouth and people talk like
that on a regular basis I was
astonished at the fact the language that
some people use with their friends or
with their loved ones yeah but it's just
I'm just talking it's just this is just
that whenever you talk
so Andrew previously there was a lot of
rumor going around why he was kicked out
of big brother and
um it was released that it was it had
something to do with
um him like attempting to hit like his
girlfriend but then the girlfriend came
out and then said oh this is like a role
play thing that we did it is possible
that what we see right there is also a
role play it's a really good point as
well it could be something that is a
kink of his and that he's into because
that video looked really bad it did look
really good it's real bad and she's like
yeah we're just playing guys if if they
have a substantial map the lawyer should
be working to get a substantial amount
of witnesses that say oh no I have
similar text messages with him but it
was like a thing that we do you know but
I will say that the likelihood of each
of these points to me starts to paint
him um in a much worse light every
during every the WhatsApp conversations
the videos have been coming out my gut
is just telling me there's gonna be more
information that comes out that puts a
lot of this in context because I feel
like his whole career has been like
taken out of context like he's an
Entertainer